[Music]
what do you want when i become a
millionaire
a million dollars nope too much that's a
lot that's a lot of big ass
i don't know if i have a hundred
thousand dollars would i give you a
thousand yeah well you have a hundred
thousand right now just give him a
thousand no
yeah you should do that joe
well what i'm trying to get at is that
this story here is
they found some buried treasure
fancy and exciting does that sound it
was actually in a library and they found
someone's stash of weed
and some gum chill dude
from the is that 80s chew
yeah or it's called something else
godzilla do you guys remember
those big chew that you open it and it's
like spaghetti
you know isaac isaac has uh he's been
wanting it for a long time and then they
somehow
found it somewhere like his dad found it
somewhere and he got him a whole bunch
so now he has a [ __ ] ton of that bigly
can you bring me some
can you just get it from the ice cream
truck i guess they don't sell it anymore
well the best thing about it is that it
conditions kids to want to
eat dinner yeah tobacco i mean they
actually had gum cigars
gum cigarettes i love those they're
great that's probably why i became a
[ __ ]
nicotine addict dude it's nicotine
nicotine
snickers no smoker and nicotine because
one of my favorite things was to buy the
cigarettes
from the uh uh [ __ ] i think that's
why you became a smoker though
yeah i was i smoked too and i said
one day [ __ ] it's gonna be real
it's gonna be
yeah like you just wait long i'm gonna
show you what the [ __ ] is up
watch out [ __ ] yeah that was me every
time it was cold and like
my breath could be all foggy like all
the time me and nikki fake smoke
sometimes just because it's funny
and we'll see how long we can do it do
you guys say darling guys you do it
like we're outside recently and say uh
like uh just on our patio
and we're just like fake smoking like
across the room there's like 30 minutes
that is that the longest yeah that's
long so far that's a long pretense it's
actually very relaxing you guys should
do it for like a full day where she's
like you're cooking and she's like
holding it on the
like on her [ __ ] lips and she's like
playing along the whole time let's see
how like [ __ ]
and then she talks and it goes like this
imaginarily though
i just hope it doesn't get worse you
know because that's just we could we
could really get into some serious [ __ ]
you're like doing it right now
you can't put it down can you just what
i'm saying i don't wanna i don't wanna
eventually it never mind yeah we're fake
we're fake doing
crack no no actually you guys end up
getting lung cancer and then
because you've been oh man you went from
imagination that sounds like never mind
oh no oh it's the nose
after we're imaginarily in the hospital
you know the imaginary like smoking
through the throat is what i was trying
to lead to
oh yeah so he's still addicted but he
has to get surgery now to smoke
this whole time it's [ __ ] invisible
that's what made me laugh
that escalated very quickly for my
anyway yeah so then this one so they're
saying that they were able to date
the beer to the 80s because
uh oh well godzilla heads dates to the
late 80s but then the beer's lack of
printed warning labels that have been
required for alcohol containers since
november of 1988
was missing from these beers they were
like oh [ __ ] it's from
somewhere around the late 80s can we
find the owner does the work mabel help
anybody who who's the person who's like
oh no [ __ ] oh i'm not gonna a warning
yeah oh no it's just to not get sued
right
pretty much i don't know when i looked
at the cigarette boxes like may affect
pregnant women i'm like
thank god i'm not pregnant homie no
sometimes i'll show you like
a like a dying child over there and
you're like oh [ __ ] it's some black
lungs or like
tongue in asia in europe i've seen that
i've seen it a lot remember junior high
pick up pack cigarettes and it says
surgeon general i don't even know
no surgeon generals yeah why would there
be a general of all the surgeries yeah
my [ __ ] this full
and i just yeah what is a surgeon
general we had
i feel like we talked about this
recently they're supposed to be the
nation's doctor but you don't see this
whole talking yeah how come dr faustie's
coming out where's the general
no cause i remember bringing up in this
show that i said yeah i saw him he's a
black guy
he is yeah but why isn't he talking
about this [ __ ] labradoodle breeder
coming out of town his phone number is
one yeah
one eight hundred general now nice
that's not the surge in general
isn't that the carpet guy no insurance
oh yeah there's a carpet one though too
it's a carpet generally 899
it works wow i miss jingles man they're
they're they're not
just still out there dude especially in
the radio for those car dealerships yeah
go see hell go see you look i mean like
mom won't get a lemon
like new company i would have got a
lemon like a manscape jingle
mask if you guys can do jingle oh yeah
they should do you should make one for
them
jingle dingle jingle dingle no the thing
that's popular now is like the one guy
who's talking to the camera
it's like throw away your piece of [ __ ]
blank you need this oh yeah that guy's
everywhere
oh yeah everyone ever since the old
spice yeah i hate his face now
he made me hate his face the guy who's
like hey you know you have your
deodorant [ __ ]
oh that guy it was [ __ ] yeah yeah i hate
that guy now
i at first i didn't care that much but
now he's so everywhere yeah
i don't watch commercials where do you
guys see these on youtube youtube
pre-rolls pre-rolls yeah post rolls
period pay for
premium youtube baby you're the only
chump
you didn't want to watch cobra kai no i
i got over it
[Laughter]
you don't use ad blocker i have brave
browser
like well maybe we we shouldn't add
blockers
yeah if you guys use ad blocker take it
off take it off for jk news just take
them off
just for us for a barton geo channel
all over the channel okay and this is a
real money so i
you know look nothing in between
so i'm gonna need the ad revenue guys we
need to add whatever you need you
started this video with saying
bart goes you have a hundred gang give
nelson give nelson son
really smooth really really smooth
nelson
if i was a billionaire i promise you
this
i'll give you a million why only nelson
a billionaire how about the rest of us
because you guys don't need money he's
my poor friend
but nelson owns a hall
uh you have more money than i do what
what are you talking about i don't even
have central air
i'm dying right now do you guys
understand i'm a homeowner
no i live inland it's like 110 degrees
i'll buy you air conditioning we have
like one room with the portable air
conditioner
that we just like hide in so we can do
it i feel like you are so good with
tools and equipment though you could
build your own building
air conditioner yep i believe in you why
can't you why do you think you can
i did look at the fan and the cup of ice
oh i saw that
yeah that was my age the fan has a
seizure every time you turn it on
[Laughter]
oh my god we gotta do that challenge
with joe why do you think that we
that i i won't give you a million
dollars if i'm a billionaire
because you literally said no to him yes
please you said what do you want if i
have a millionaire you said what do you
want he said a million dollars you said
no when you said you were because i
won't be a millionaire anymore if i gave
him a million dollars well when you said
you were gonna give me money you you
gave me this earlier that's 10 grand i
can't i can't get a million of these
okay i don't think it would make me any
better i should have been specific
okay if i had a million dollars be
pacific please what would you want
you can't take all my money well you
said if you had a hundred thousand
you give them a thousand and you
literally just earned a hundred thousand
today and i was like giving us a
thousand
nah right now i'm good you don't even
have to put up
why did you even volunteer nobody even
asked you right
now you're in debt dude you just got
yourself a debt and you're a dick
you owe everyone in this room money now
why did i do that to myself
how did you do it i don't know why do i
i'm the kind of guy that'll bargain
and you're like they'll be like yeah
it's 100 bucks and i'm like no 10
000 yeah that is you and i'm like why
did i do that right now
you're bargaining but no you're not even
buying it i actually did that with my
plumber the other day other day he came
in as a
he diagnosed everything and i was like
how much do i owe you he goes oh we
could deal with that later
and then i called my landlord and she
had a different uh plumber come and fix
it and i was like
hey man um how much do i owe you for
diagnosing everything he goes don't
worry about it i'm like
nah i gotta get you paid for your time
man and then so i told the landlord hey
i'm gonna pay him you gotta pay me back
and she's like all right we could
compensate him and i was like send me a
bill
and he didn't he didn't do it why are
you chasing people to get bills
pay them yeah i don't know man i to me
i'm just
i think it's more like the principle
behind things like
um they i did work with them before they
did a good job and i think they gave me
a good
good price so i'm like okay well uh
i don't know it's weird if he told me
don't worry about it the next down he
would hear is my
is the click from hanging up the [ __ ]
phone
don't get me wrong i like a good deal
man i go on groupon i still
look for deals yeah i forgot about
groupon
yo right now twenty dollars for two
hours paddle board boarding and balboa
go check that [ __ ] out don't go paddle
boarding
yeah that's that's a good price right do
you want to go outside right now though
i don't know i'm down
it's only 80 degrees out there oh out
there okay
with the breeze 80 degrees with the
breeze and warm water don't you see our
color is different
like we've just been out in the sun the
whole time i'm pretty tan
yeah you are i started my tan in new
jersey
wow cool
you go out for a day and then you come
huntiest thing i've ever heard
thank you thank you you know everyone
thought it
everyone like looked around like what do
we say to that
i love it you get 10 super easy where
like if you come back you immediately
have a short tan line yup i already got
one right now
this one like a date oh yeah yeah my
melanin strong homie
i think that's one of the perks of being
asian you got a free sun
care because what ends up happening is
you can be
as pale as this tissue paper
like a geisha in the winter and then in
the summer
if you tan slowly it becomes protection
so i don't get sunburned if i can get a
good coat going
but i can't do it overnight if i go
overnight that [ __ ]
burns like a [ __ ] currently do
you need some blockado
not now i'm tanned enough to where i
don't need sunblock i could be out there
for like
four hours me too yeah but bart turns
purple bart bart's got crazy superpowers
out of his hands you tan purple
he'll be on the side he goes purple and
then he'll go to red and he'll go to tan
but yeah i don't it's really hard for me
to burn
but i can keep tanning like forever you
burn all the time
he does burn and peel yeah it's so funny
now you don't because of what joe just
said where you've layered i do burn all
the time
all the [ __ ] every time the second
day in hawaii you're cause you're always
like oh my god you're burnt i'm like i'm
not
bro we were we were imitation crab in
hawaii do you remember that
that day that day i was burnt that day
we snorkeled so much because it was our
first snorkeling experience
that our heads were just in the water
right so half of our bodies was expected
bags were all boiled up and [ __ ] wasn't
it
because we were there for like five
hours were you at that snorkel spot
the uh what's it called we were
somewhere else
but that place is awesome dude though
that place is sick dude i did that that
was awesome
you know what i heard because of the
quarantinos a lot of the fish and
wildlife
is coming back oh we gotta go we gotta
go we gotta we gotta go we gotta go ruin
it
[Music]
you